[Música]
continúan las tensiones entre china eeuu
y taiwán por la visita de congresistas
estadounidenses que apoyan la democracia
de la isla tras años de hostilidades y
tensiones desde la guerra civil y taiwán
entonces ha conseguido protegerse de la
amenaza de una invasión china entre
otras cosas porque es líder en una
industria clave de los semiconductores
de la que pueden que dependen desde la
fabricación de aviones de combate hasta
paneles solares videojuegos o
instrumentos médicos entre muchos otros
materiales saludamos entonces en este
momento a fernando pedrós ale ese
profesor de la carrera de ciencia
política de la facultad de ciencias
sociales donde coordina el grupo de
estudios de asia y américa latina'
profesor fernando gracias por estar
nuevamente con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24
muy buena mañana de lunes empecemos
entonces por analizar digamos lo que
representa esta nueva visita de los
altos funcionarios estadounidenses a
taiwán
buen día raúl cómo estás bueno esta
visita implica continuar el camino
abierto por la visita de nancy pelosi
realizada unos días atrás no así que me
parece que eeuu habrá evaluado que los
resultados políticos de esa visita
fueron positivos y continuamos este
camino que tiene un bajo costo en el
sentido que no son armas nos lleva a
barcos no tiene ninguna amenaza
inmediata pero que está generando una
repercusión muy fuerte en el mundo y la
propia china claro y precisamente hoy
tras esta visita de dos días y tras
reunirse con la presidenta de la isla
saint win el gobierno chino pues dijo
que iba a continuar digamos con estos
ejercicios militares de fuego real
realmente estos ejercicios militares del
profesor representaría una amenaza
bueno son una advertencia una muestra
del poder chino una señal de que podrían
movilizar las tropas y los aviones en
forma muy rápida me parece que no hoy no
no pasa de ahí no creo que también hay
que resaltar que la visita de los
legisladores norteamericanos fue de
ambos partidos fondos cinco legisladores
encabezado por un senador pero había
miembros demócratas y republicanos lo
cual les da también una mirada de
continuidad
a la política que ya venía de la época
de trump hacia la de bailén me parece
que el gesto código fuerte y china está
enquistada como encerrada en la opción
militar no está evaluando otras opciones
no está pensando en opciones políticas
sino que está pensando demostrar su
poderío lo que
llamamos o sea mostrando los dientes no
me parece que por ahora está ahí yo que
lo quisiera pedir bueno esperemos que
así sea también pero hablemos el
profesor de la importancia estrategia y
también económica de la isla de taiwán
bueno vos anticipa esto un poquito los
superconductores yo diría bueno además
hay un tema geográfico básicamente no
nos recuerda mucho aunque no tiene que
ver exactamente pero nos recuerdan mucho
del caso de cuba con eeuu el caso de
wang con china no a una isla pequeñita
al lado del gigante con sistemas
políticos diferentes o sea que la
ubicación geográfica nos da una
importancia clave pero además de eso la
industria de los servicios y conductores
es fundamental para el mundo nos damos
una serie de
artículos en los que se utiliza pero
también se usa en aviones de combate por
ejemplo entidades militares es
obviamente la televisión en los
teléfonos una guerra te costaría al
mundo tres años por lo menos en
recuperar una industria que es clave
para la vida como la conocemos
básicamente claro digamos vamos a seguir
andando en esto porque muchos analistas
también consideran que esto ha sido una
una especie digamos de escudo protector
de taiwán para una eventual invasión
tiene una posible invasión china que
recordemos que reclama taiwán a como
propio está en su política de una sola
china incluyendo a taiwán usted
concuerda con este con este análisis
digamos de estos estos expertos
esta reflexión de silicio el tema de
bueno para uno dar unos datos
taiwán tiene varias empresas que hace en
casa semiconductores sumadas todas
tienen un 63 por ciento de mercado
ese 63 por ciento mercado también es
china
o sea que chinas y destruyera la vida
productiva de taiwán también estaría
perjudicada
inmediatamente cuando se dice que bueno
destruir taiwán garantizaría también una
destrucción o un problema para todos no
solamente para para eeuu no para taiwán
misma así que yo creo que hoy por hoy
efectivamente mientras china no
desarrolle una industria desde pesos
similares semiconductores cosas
intentando hacer porque también ha
generado una especie de ley donde
pone 150.000 millones de dólares para
garantizar la fabricación de estos son
conductores hasta el ambiente se
mantenga está este predominio tiene un
seguro más digamos es totalmente seguro
estas cosas pero tiene un seguro más
claro profesores también digamos
volviendo a estas visitas diplomáticas
diplomáticas de alto nivel que empezaron
recordemos con la visita de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi ya
otra delegación estadounidense están ahí
yo quisiera saber también si otras
países a lo mejor la unión europea
también lo que estábamos conversando el
día ayer que podría enviar una
delegación de diplomáticos o digamos
porque occidente en este momento lo está
realizando
bueno en gran bretaña que enseñó europea
pero ha anunciado que demandará una
visita y realmente una presencia cada
vez mayor en la zona eso también es
importante
señalarlo desde que se va que se fue de
la unión europea está teniendo una
política en la que busca retomar cierto
liderazgo
poniendo el énfasis en la región también
te quiero decir que otros motivos de la
visita es que eeuu votó hace un poquito
la llamada ley de chips y ciencia que es
una ley para no solo estimular la
creación de superconductores sino para
evitar que las empresas asociadas a
capitales norteamericanos
trabajen con china y esa ley digamos
invierte 52 mil millones de dólares para
fortalecer la industria norteamericana
en el tema de los semiconductores y los
chips así que evidentemente esto está en
el centro del problema y cada país no
solo está intentando evitar que el otro
crezca sino también estimular su propia
industria y su propia creación
científica claro volviendo entonces al
tema de chinelo semiconductores entonces
estaría en una carrera contra el loco
esto intensificaría la carrera de china
para hacer una potencia digamos en estos
semiconductores tan necesarios para todo
casi que lo que usamos diariamente
y totalmente por eso en general los
especialistas en geopolítica piensan que
este no es el momento final del
enfrentamiento de eeuu y china todavía
esto puede pasar después de 2030 hasta
el 2050 es decir todavía china tiene que
recorrer un largo camino antes de
convertirse una potencia en la que pueda
satisfacer sus propias demandas no sólo
alimenticias energéticas sino
tecnológicas en este caso china es una
superpotencia de la número 2 y por un
tiempo todavía va a seguir siéndolo
fernando es posible esta unificación de
taiwán con china realmente y yo creo que
a corto plazo no
no lo va a ser pacíficamente en la
práctica está igual ya llevamos desde
1949 sea mucho tiempo funcionando
independientemente de china con lo cual
también dentro de está igual si hay
generación que se consideran taiwaneses
eso es un tema que también hay que tomar
en cuenta dentro de taiwán no hay alguna
gente quiere unificarse con china
todavía que son los mayores los que
recuerdan todavía en los viejos sucesos
pero las nuevas generaciones han nacido
en un país que en la práctica es
independiente en la playa cotidiana de
ellos es independiente entonces yo creo
que eso también está generando las
raíces para considerar que en algún
momento hay que poner a discutir
seriamente y por fuera en lo militar
cuál va a ser el tema de taiwán y su
relación con china con el mundo